are there any parts of chester that have
maybe rubbed off on you
oh yeah i mean i definitely like in the
at the thrift store or shopping for
clothes and i'm like
should i get a crop top i definitely
have like looked at
but i've taken a lot of my hoodies in my
closet and just like cut off the bottom
i'm like so into like because i'm naked
all the time on set so i'm like why not
just be naked in like real life too
all right well justice uh
congratulations on generation i want to
ask you first like what has
this role meant to you and also what
does it mean to see the response to the
show
uh it's meant the world you know like i
feel like characters like this
are normally centralized you know we
don't tell their stories
as um if they were the main characters
like they're often like the best friend
or whatever
so here we have this like openly
unapologetic queer person who's loud and
proud
and he's like at the center of this
story um so
i'm really honored to be able to portray
that and to like
represent um that and
uh the response is amazing the way the
fans are engaging with the show
is just like incredible it makes me so
happy i i'm always watching like
the fan cams of riley and greta
i'm always like i'm so invested in
bradley and greta getting together
like i know what happened but right i'm
like so like with the fans like
watching all over there with yes exactly
exactly
i'm just i'm so into it
so let's talk about chester because when
we first beat your character
he's swagged out i'm sorry he's just so
confident
and i don't know about you that was not
me in high school uh and i know there's
more than meets the i2 chester but can
you relate to that
like that that sense of confidence what
was your high school experience like
oh not in high school no no no no i've
always been like a
relatively loud person and and i feel
like uh
i'm i'm like set in my ways i'm a little
bit stubborn
and um i let it known that i'm here so i
have that in common with chester
but not when it comes to fashion i was a
little more meek and
i was experimenting i i didn't really
know who i was i was trying to
figure it out experimenting i felt like
i was conforming and that's like
oh yeah yeah but now right now yeah yeah
when you're on the other side of it now
exactly you just touch on that a little
bit but uh so what would you say is one
thing you have in common with chester
but what would you say is also the
biggest difference
um whoa i mean one is he's
in high school and i i think that he
he's um very deeply sensitive and is
so obsessed with being honest and like
authentic to who he is that he often
like is provocative
for provocation's sake and um i'm a
little more
um considerate i think about how other
people are going to perceive me um
not in a way that sacrifices who i am it
sacrifices my authenticity but just in a
way that's just like
that person can't handle me being blunt
right now so i probably shouldn't be
but chester is not like that justice
raymond was like i will be blunt
because you need to hear this thing is i
am a star water polo player
with a 4.1 gpa and my tolerance for
giving a
is like minimal where do you come down
on cursing
safe space what do you hope that young
queer people take away from this show
i just hope they see themselves
represented you know that's what we set
out to do
um it's created by queers the majority
of the cast is queer
majority of the writers room is queer it
is just like
a big celebration of where we've come as
queer people
um generation z is the most queer
generation
um i can't imagine the generation after
them and
and how open and fluid they're gonna be
so this is just
like a way to represent to honor to
respect
to celebrate just like all the joy
and love and goodness of being queer
um yeah and i hope queer people love it
that's that's what matters to me the
world
last june obviously you posted about the
lack of support for trans and lgbtq
people of color and many took that as
you coming out
was that the case at the time and what
do you feel about that experience when
you look back at it now
um i mean i personally disagree with the
term coming out just because i think
that it puts the onus on
the marginalized individual to like they
have
an obligation to the larger public like
i don't think it should work like that
so i i tweeted i didn't come out y'all
came in with because i when i knew i was
queer like all my friends and fans
knew like it wasn't something that i hid
as soon as i figured
out i was like oh yeah this is this is
who i am but i just wanted to make sure
in that moment
like at the height of black lives matter
that i wanted to make sure that i was
aligning myself with my community and
that publicly people knew that
i was experiencing this pain on an
intimate level
because it's my community you know so um
that's that's kind of what i was trying
to do
and the response was you know good and
and
what i what i didn't want to do was make
it about
me um like that was like a really kind
of like hard thing to balance was like
how do i talk about this issue but not
center myself because it's not about me
it's about this like
community within my community um
but i was like just the nature of people
following me to see me
like i have i have a responsibility or
more of an opportunity
to like speak out about something i have
ears that will listen
so um i'm going to do what i can you
know that's all i can do
so did you feel or do you feel like
there's a sense of freedom
almost because you are openly queer to
the broader public
uh yeah yes
yeah i i mean it's like
it's weird because you know people are
going to digest your queerness in the
way that they do you know especially
like
popular culture as always try to
categorize
and box queerness and serve it on a
platter and be like this is what it is
and this is how they should act and this
is what they like and this is
and so like i had to get used to that
and like people trying to like
put me in a weird box but also the
beauty and joy of being queer is that it
is this
unboxable thing it's so fluid and like
um i constantly um like
um subverting expectations you know and
i have experience with with that like
already being a marginalized identity
being a person of color
but um i i kind of had to get adjusted
to that
new um like the way people were
metabolizing my queerness
in the public eye but because i had
built so much strength you know i've
been queer my
whole life you know right like i was i
and also
having experience with that being like
black in public
like like i i have the strength to
handle like oh you don't get to define
that for me you can say what you want
about my queerness but my queerness is
my queerness and i'm going to define
that for me
what can you tease and what do you want
fans to know about where
this story ends at least for now i don't
want to spoil
but i just want to say that you see
chester kind of experience one of the
lowest
lows and um and and he starts to grapple
with
like um this ever pervasive loneliness
that
that that it just kind of hums in the
background of his life yeah
um which is very common for a lot of
queer people like queer loneliness is
such like
a thing that a lot of us grapple with
but there's also there's
this uh how do i wear this about
spoiling
um there's this um uniting event
that happens that brings all of the gsa
together
and they become a tighter knit
family than ever before that was good
yeah i do want to talk about a couple of
your other projects let's talk about
your new single bed congratulations
how's it going in the world it's scary
it's cool but it's scary um
just because like both my parents are
singers my sisters are singer um
i just never really thought that i was
going to share my music with the world
it was always just kind of like a
thing i did privately um but i
i remember what was i watching i forgot
what i was watching but it
they it said something i think it was a
star is born
where he bradley cooper talks about like
oh you
like if you have something to say or
something you should say and i was like
oh wow yeah i should say
like like i feel like i had a voice um
musically like i'm not even saying that
i'm necessarily a good singer
or a good songwriter but like i had
something to say so i was like i want to
share that with
to tell the world a story to tell so um
i'm i'm really excited to kind of start
this
journey of telling this story musically
and
um so far everyone is responding really
positively which is
good you know because i am approaching
this really tepidly but
um it's exciting it's exciting did you
just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me stop i've
been so lonely
what can you tell us about any plans for
a detective pikachu
sequel because i know we heard i think
in 2019 that a sequel was already
written
is that still the case have you read
anything yet uh listen i would love
a detective pikachu sequel i the fans
should like
write a petition or something and i
don't know what's happening with that
um but yeah i would love one i would
love one
they gotta you know make some noise or
something do you feel get them to write
it
unfinished business for your character
like yes see happen in the sequel with
him
i want um all new pokemon i want tim to
get a new pokemon partner
i want you know battles i want all the
good stuff from the games
um you know just just like that world is
so vast the pokemon world is so vast
there's so many so many stories to tell
within that world so
i feel like it's like a like a
bottomless well you can draw a poncho
yeah the fans want it you you joke they
might petition but they could
they want it i hope they do i really
hope they do